wherever there's a lot of opportunity
for money and fame there are many many
many people out there trying to do the
same and for me the competitiveness of
the industry combined with the fact that
I am Asian American where it is mostly
white men in comedy who are performing
I'm a woman I'm queer there are many
aspects to my personality that don't
really fit within the idea of what we
think of traditionally as a stand-up
comics so I was fighting a lot of
people's expectations of what comedy was
and who should be delivering the jokes
also fighting this notion of
invisibility of asian-americans or for
asian-americans in entertainment if you
really want to do something you should
just go for it and never let go and I
think that tenacity wins out over talent
tenacity will win out over any kind of
education or any kind of nepotism or any
kind I mean I think tenacity if you
really stick with it there's a reason
why you feel something there's a reason
to have a drive to do something and if
you have the drive to do something then
you should do it a lot of people make
the mistake of allowing their families
to choose their path for them they allow
other people to advise them into careers
that they don't want to be in when you
can overcome what other people's
expectations of what your lives should
be then you really won and I think that
when you do what you really really
really want when you do what's in your
heart then you really are bound to be
successful and by successful i mean the
reward is doing well
you